BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: Welcome, and
thank you for joining us today.
We're going to be
speaking about how
to build event-driven
applications on Google
Cloud using Eventarc.
My name is Bryan Zimmerman,
product manager at Google
Cloud, focusing on Eventarc.
METE ATAMEL: And my
name is Mete Atamel.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google Cloud.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: Before
getting into the details,
let's look at our
orchestration suite of products
at a high level.
Today, as we're
talking about building
event-driven
applications, Eventarc
is the product that helps
you accomplish this easily.
Along with Workflows,
Tasks, and Scheduler,
Eventarc is part of
a suite of products
that are fully
managed, flexible,
and enterprise-ready to
help you accomplish all
of your orchestration needs.
Eventarc connects to
over 60 GCP services
through its integration
with cloud audit logs.
In addition, our integration
with Pub/Sub as a source
allows you to use
Eventarc for events raised
from your own application.
As far as targets, we currently
support Cloud Run in GA
and Cloud Run for Anthos,
and functions in preview.
Our other products
support even more targets
through HTTP execution.
Together, these fully
managed and flexible products
help developers connect
the cloud with less code.
In our demo today,
you will see many
of these products in action--
specifically, Eventarc,
Workflows, Cloud Run,
and Cloud Functions.
So what do we mean by
event-driven architecture?
First, let's talk about
the modern application.
Here's an example of
a simple application
with a complex web of service
teams working together
towards a common goal.
This application is
somewhat complicated
with interactions
and dependencies
that can become a
drag on velocity.
But in reality, today
your application
is more likely to look like
this, an extremely complex web
of point-to-point
interactions creating
a significant number
of dependencies
and points of failure.
As applications
expand horizontally,
connections become
even more complex
and difficult to understand.
While microservice
patterns provide
a great deal of
advantages, they also
come with a great
deal of complexity.
By contrast,
event-driven architecture
produces a solution
for this problem.
It provides the ability
to reduce dependencies
and complexity in
your application
while still allowing
the creation of more
and more microservices.
Event-driven architecture allows
true separation of concern.
A producer need not
know how an event will
be consumed or take
on any dependency
from a downstream service.
Similarly, the
consumer only needs
to know that the event will
be raised and understand
how to utilize it,
none of the details
of the upstream service.
With this loosely
coupled approach,
we eliminate hard
dependencies between services
and eliminate that
drag on velocity.
In a traditional
application, you can only
scale one way, vertically.
With event-driven
architecture, a developer
is easily able to
scale an application
as performance needs increase.
Furthermore, imagine
a scenario where
you're adding a new service
to an existing application.
In a point-to-point
signaling model,
upstream services
must be updated
in order to signal the
downstream services.
However, in an
event-driven pattern,
users are easily able
to add a new service
from existing events
without updating
the upstream application at all.
This helps to
eliminate that spider
web of concerns and
point-to-point interactions
substantially.
Eventarc is Google's
solution to this problem.
It is a managed
eventing system that
makes building event-driven
serverless applications easy.
Simply select the Google
Cloud service or Pub/Sub
topic you're interested
in as a source,
define the filter
parameters, and choose
the target you wish to invoke.
We do use Pub/Sub in the
background as a transport layer
to benefit from its superior
reliability and observability,
but we take care of all
the details of setup.
Simply create that
trigger, and we'll
take care of the event
ingress, the filtering,
and the delivery of events
to your desired target.
Lastly, we use the CNCF
Standard cloud events format.
And because of this, it's
easy to understand and marshal
the details of your
events in order
to more intelligently
drive application behavior.
Now I'd like to share
an important customer
story from one of our
customers, Vivint.
Vivint is an
exciting IoT company.
They currently power
the smart home for
over 1.8 million customers.
Their portfolio of devices is
impressive, offering smart home
bundles that cover
everything from cameras
to locks to important sensors
such as flood sensors.
As these devices are
important for ensuring
your home is running
smoothly and safely,
latency and reliability
of the backend system
is extremely important for
creating the right customer
experience.
Let's talk a bit about the
challenge they were facing.
In 2020, Vivint was presented
with an exciting business
opportunity.
They intended to offer a
standalone doorbell camera
outside of their
smart home bundle.
This was an interesting
technical challenge.
Their core system,
you see, was built
around the concept of bundles,
so this standalone offering
was a significant
departure from that model.
Lastly, time to market
really mattered.
There was a limited
window they had in
which to make this
happen in order
to address this
fast-moving market segment.
Here's what they
built. By leveraging
events and serverless
technology,
they were able to separate
the components needed
to run the camera application
from the core platform
without having to
rewrite everything,
and without adding any risk
or instability to the user
experience of either
the new application
or their core offering.
Let's examine in detail the
architecture used for their use
case, or one of their
use cases specifically,
an image processing pipeline
for their camera application.
Images were loaded from
the camera to a GCS bucket.
This invoked a Cloud
Function or Cloud
Run for Anthos Service, which
analyzed the images using
the Computer Vision API in
order to categorize and annotate
appropriately.
The results were
updated in a BigQuery
data set for use later.
And the frontend platform was
signaled via an integration
with Pub/Sub.
Firebase FCM was used in
order to send notifications
to the mobile app, and
their core platform
received the event
for historical reasons
and tracking.
The result, Eventarc and
GCP surveillance technology
allowed them to accelerate time
to value and time to market.
Not only did these products
help solve their problem
but did so in a way
that would scale,
and by achieving
separation of concern
without risking their
core technology.
To dig into some of
the secondary benefits,
this provided a number
of things that were
really interesting to them.
First, it decreased the time
to market, as I mentioned.
The backend system was
developed and ready to go
earlier than expected.
They were also able to
implement continuous deployment.
They deployed new code
after every two-week sprint.
This is an improvement over the
previous quarterly OTA updates.
By using event processing
in the same location,
they were also able to--
sorry, in the same location
as the notification
service, they
were also able to
decrease latency by 78%.
And finally, built entirely
on managed serverless
and orchestration
products, the new solution
was scalable even in the
most successful scenarios.
Vivint didn't have to
worry about scalability out
of the gate, as they
were able to rest
assured in the confidence
of Google Cloud's ability
to scale.
Hopefully, Vivint's
story helps exemplify
how Eventarc and Google Cloud
can help accelerate time
to value for your organization.
To help understand how this can
work for you in the real world,
Mete has created a demo of
a similar image processing
pipeline.
So with this said, I will
hand things over to Mete.
METE ATAMEL: Thanks, Bryan.
I'll show you a simplified
image processing pipeline.
In this pipeline, users drop
images in a Cloud Storage
bucket.
These images will be processed
by a chain of Cloud Run
and Cloud Function services.
We use Eventarc to trigger
the pipeline via Cloud Run,
and Workflows to orchestrate
the services that
process the images.
Let's have a look.
OK.
Before running the
demo, let's look
at the architecture diagram.
First, we have end users saving
some images to an input bucket.
Once the image is saved,
this generates an event,
and this event goes to a
Filter Cloud Run service.
Now, this event is routed
using Eventarc's Cloud Storage
trigger.
Now the filter service
will receive the image,
and it will use Vision API to
determine if it's a safe image
or not.
If the image is
safe, then the filter
starts a Workflow execution.
This Workflow execution,
called image processing,
will call a number
of Cloud Functions.
The first Cloud Function
is called Labeler.
Labeler will receive
the image and again, it
will use Vision API to extract
the labels out of the image.
And it will save them
to an output bucket.
Then Workflows will call
a Resizer Cloud Function.
This will take the image, and
resize it into 400 by 400,
and save it to that
bucket as well.
And then there will
be another function
called Watermarker that
will receive the labels
from the first function.
And it will also receive
the resized image.
And it will add a
watermark using the labels
on the resized image.
And then it will save
it to the output bucket.
As you can see, these are
three separate functions,
but they're orchestrated
together using Workflows.
So how do you set
something like this?
We'll take a look.
But before I show you the code
and the setup, all of the code
is on GitHub, and all the
instructions are on GitHub.
So feel free to check
it out yourself as well.
Now first, let's take a
look at what we need to do.
So this is the GitHub page.
And before you begin, you
need to set up the project ID.
You need to enable the APIs
that we need with Eventarc
and Workflows and others.
Then we need to pick a region.
And we need to set
our Cloud Run region
and our Eventarc
location to that region.
And then we need to configure
some service accounts,
because we're going to use
them in Eventarc triggers.
So we want to make sure
that we have a service
account with
eventarc.eventReceiver role.
And we also need a
pubsub.publisher role
for the Cloud Storage trigger.
And we also want to make
sure that our Pub/Sub service
account has the
serviceAccountTokenCreator
role.
Now, once we have all of those--
and I already set all of this--
we need to create storage
buckets for our images.
So we create one bucket
for the input images
and another bucket
for output images.
So this is where the images
will be saved by the users,
and this is where the
processing will happen
and the output images
will be saved as well.
All right.
Then we can start
deploying our services.
If you remember, we had
three Cloud Functions,
Watermarker,
Resizer, and Labeler,
that are orchestrated
together in a workflow.
So let's look at
Watermarker first.
Watermarker is a C# function,
but it can be in any language.
And to look at the code
quickly, what it does
is that first, we read the
bucket name as an environment
variable.
This is the output
bucket where we're
going to save the image
once we process it.
Then we receive HTTP
request in this method.
And from the HTTP request, we
extract a couple of things.
First, we extract the bucket
and the file information
so we can download the image.
And then we also
extract the labels that
will be passed in by Workflows.
And we're going to use these
labels to add a watermark.
Then we download the
image from the bucket.
Then in this piece of code, we
use an image processing library
to use the labels and add a
watermark on top of the image.
And then finally,
we save the image
with the watermarks
to the output bucket.
All right.
Now, to deploy this service
we just use gcloud deploy.
We specify the
runtime as dotnet3.
We make sure that this is
an HTTP triggered function.
And we also pass in the
environment variable
for the bucket so that the
function knows how to save--
where to save the image.
So once this is deployed,
we can move on to Resizer.
Resizer is very similar to
the previous Watermarker.
But instead of adding a
watermark, it resizes.
And we deploy it pretty
much the same way.
You can check out
the code if you like.
And then Labeler is, again,
very similar function.
Instead of resizing the image,
it extracts the labels out
of the image.
And it uses Vision
API to do that.
So if we take a look
at the code quickly,
you can see that the Labeler
will receive the bucket
and file information,
then it will
call this ExtractLabelsAsync
method with the storage
URL of the image.
And if you look
at this method, it
basically uses the
Vision API client
and calls the DetectLabelsAsync
to extract the labels.
Then we order the
labels by score.
And we return them in
a list that we use.
So once we return the
labels, what we do
is that we first save
these labels in a text
file to the output bucket.
And then we also extract the
top three of these labels
and return them as
HTTP response data.
And we're going to use this
from Workflows as well.
OK.
So that's Labeler.
And now we need to put
this into an orchestration.
And we do that with Workflows.
And to define the workflow, we
create a workflow.yaml file.
And then we'll define what
happens in that YAML file.
So let's take a look
at that quickly here.
So in workflow.yaml file, first
it receives some arguments.
This will be coming from
our Cloud Run service
that I'm going to show you next.
And in these arguments,
we have the information
about the bucket and the file.
And we also pass in the
URLs or our services.
Because we don't
want to hardcode
these URLs of these
functions, so instead
we passed them in as arguments.
Then we have our steps.
In the first steps, we log our
bucket and file information
just to make sure that we
are on the right track.
Than in the label
step, we make a call
to the Labeler URL, which is
the URL of the Labeler function.
And we pass in the
bucket and file.
And then this calls
the Labeler function.
And then we get the
response from the function
and save it to
labelResponse variable,
Then we do the same
with resize step.
So in the resize step,
you just call the Resizer
and capture the response
in resizeResponse.
Then in watermark step,
we call the Watermarker,
but we pass in the bucket
and file information
from the resize step.
This is because we want
to add the watermark
for the resized image, right?
So because of that, we pass
in the resized image's bucket
and file information.
And we also pass in the labels
from the label response.
Because these are the
labels that we extracted
from the Labeler function, so
we are passing them in as well.
And the Watermarker
will use those labels
to add the watermark.
And then in the final step,
we return the HTTP status
code from all the
steps, just to make sure
that our workflow
completed successfully.
OK.
So that's workflow.
And to deploy our
workflow, all we need to do
is just use gcloud
workflows deploy.
So let's just copy
this, and go back here,
and deploy our workflow.
So this will look at
our workflow.yaml.
And now it's deploying
our workflow, which
is very quick, as you can see.
Great.
Now the next step is
the filter function.
So if you go back to our
architecture diagram,
we deployed our functions,
we deployed our workflows.
Now we need to deploy the
Filter Cloud Run service.
And we need to
make sure that it's
connected to Cloud
Storage events
using a Cloud Storage trigger.
Now, to deploy the filter,
this is a Cloud Run service.
So it's-- we need a Docker file,
and we need to build and push
the image.
So that's what we
are doing here.
And then we also deploy
the Cloud Run service
using gcloud run deploy,
and point to our image,
and pass in some
environment variables.
These variables, like the
project ID, region, workflow
name, this is the information
needed for the workflow.
But we are also
passing in the URLs
or our functions, the
Labeler URL, the Resizer URL.
That way, we don't need to
hardcode them in our workflow.
Now, this, I already did this.
But now we need to connect Cloud
Run service to Cloud Storage
events.
And we do that with
triggers in Eventarc.
So we create a
trigger name, and then
we just create a trigger
with this command.
Here we are saying that this
trigger connects this Cloud Run
service in this region.
And it's filtering these events.
These events, as you can see,
it's the Cloud Storage object
finalize event.
This is the event that gets
triggered when you save a file
and we're also
filtering on the bucket.
So let's copy this as
well, and go back here
and create our trigger.
So this will create
the Eventarc trigger.
And now everything
pretty much set.
We have our workflow.
We have our Cloud Run.
We have our trigger.
Now, to test, we need to drop
an image and see what happens.
So let's make sure
that our trigger is
created, that it's created.
And if I do gcloud
eventarc triggers list,
we can see that the
triggers are running.
Now, to test this out, let's
go to our Cloud Storage bucket.
And you can see that I
have an input bucket.
So let's upload a
couple of pictures here.
So I will upload one
picture of myself.
And then I'll upload another
beach kind of picture.
So let's upload these.
And now this starts
up the whole chain.
And if we go to
the output bucket,
we should start
seeing some images.
So now I will wait a little bit.
So you can see that we have some
labels for the first picture.
So if you click on the labels
and look at the actual file,
these are the labels that were
extracted from my picture.
Now the next one we see is
the picture that's resized.
This is the 400 to 400 picture,
so it's resized to 400 to 400.
And finally, the third
picture is the resized image
with the watermark.
And the watermark is
just the top three labels
from the image.
And just to show the
other image as well,
if you look at
the beach, you see
that it has water, cloud,
and sky as the watermark.
So this concludes the demo.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Thanks very much.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN:
Thank you, Mete.
It is great to see our
products work together
to help customers
connect to cloud,
with less code of course.
Today, we've
discussed what we have
to offer in our orchestration
and serverless products; how
our customer Vivint has
used this to accelerate time
to value; and even shown a
demo that you can try yourself
via the GitHub link that Mete
has provided to gain experience
with the concepts.
To learn even more, there
are several other sessions
that can teach you about other
related serverless technology.
And of course, please
visit us at google.com.
Thank you again for
spending us time today.
I hope you enjoyed it
as much as we have.